[Applause]
so to tap the cushion look for the
pick-and-roll is someone to the corner
not a separate second there's a pretty
doctor stuck
here's one
[Applause]
Oh
hey stuttered he has the Lakers coming
over 42-point Wolf's cutting off all the
trade speculation
to Boston and defeat the Sussex walk 29
on the last second shot mother won't
drive chauffeur
rock rock rock oh that's the way to come
home that's the way to remind people
what you did for what a wonderful plane
you knew it was going to be a pick and
roll
Hayward hopped up on the corners he
tried to come in but this is why you
keep it alive
Chandler played less than five minutes
this whole game he tips it out Rondo
with the kiss knocking it down making
sure that he gets this win so important
for guys to come home to that all arenas
get the game Chandler again less than
five minutes played in this game Rondo
bang what a tremendous game between two
longtime rivals and LeBron James with 28
points 12 rebounds 12 assists
[Applause]
and the three-point shot going fight the
Lakers with a franchise record 22 3/4
Kuzma 25 points hit that key three-point
shot 17th for the game
Blanco 70